bye
sweet corn is an important vegetable
crop in the northeast
freshly picked locally grown sweet corn
is popular among consumers
who like to be able to buy it at
roadside stands farmers markets
and supermarkets to grow a marketable
crop of sweet corn
farmers must provide adequate soil
fertility
control insect pests and manage weeds
in this video farmers describe
production practices that they use to
grow a good crop of corn without
excessive use of fertilizers
insecticides or herbicides
these ecological production practices
can help enhance profits
while protecting natural resources
farmers can decide for themselves which
of these practices makes sense
for their operation
i'm alex mclennan and i farm in the
connecticut river valley in windsor
vermont
on sandy silt loam soils i grow about
50 acres of vegetables
that's about 20 acres in sweet corn
20 acres in pumpkins and about 10 acres
of green beans
i started using hairy vetch oh i'd say
about four or five years ago now
basically i was looking for something i
don't have animals i don't have
manure so i've been trying to find cover
crops that that fit in well with a
fairly intensive vegetable production so
that we don't wear out the soil
i like the veg for a source of nitrogen
because i'm looking for something with a
bit of a time release to it
as opposed to just throwing on urea and
having it having it
go into solution too quickly
i also use the vetch specifically
because i don't take land out of
production for an entire growing season
so i'm trying to have a cover crop on
the land
basically all the time that there's not
a there's not a cash crop on there
i seed vetch from 15 to 30 pounds to the
acre
the 30 pound rate gives a real nice
stand
but some years of etch seed is very
expensive and sometimes i just economize
by cutting back to a rate as low as 15
pounds i still get a reasonably good
stand with 15 pounds to the acre
that is seeded at the same time as the
oats which is usually at about a bushel
to the acre
and that seems to work out well for
giving me a fall cover
we inoculate the vetch seed
to make sure that we get good nodulation
because
the whole purpose really of the of the
hairy vetch cover crop is to get
nitrogen
fixation we turn the vetch under in
preparation for
for planting usually around the second
to third week of may i like to i like to
hold off as long as i possibly can
and get as much nitrogen out of the veg
as i can before i
plow it under hairy vetch has never been
a problem in
in in volunteer production or
or weed production we never had any
problem turning it under and killing it
very easily
without any chemical use so the vetch
gives me additional biomass a little bit
better soil structure
additional nitrogen and erosion
protection
for the winter and early spring the
major drawback to using vetch has been
the cost of the seed
but as long as it stays under two
dollars a pound i intend to continue to
use it and i think it's done a great job
in my soils